vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela blando Daniela Buen día para
usted muy buenos días Ángela Ucrania es
En definitiva la noticia de hoy en el
Reino Unido que se está hablando en el
aspecto económico pues ya hemos hablado
de esta segunda conferencia de
recuperación de Ucrania en ella el
Primer Ministro ucraniano Denise de
chimal reveló que su país necesita un
poco más de 6.000 millones de dólares
solamente en los próximos 12 meses eso
para recuperarse de la guerra tanto
Estados Unidos como la Unión Europea han
reiterado su compromiso económico el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken afirmó que su país dará
1.300 millones de dólares adicionales y
la comisión europea también comprometió
recursos para el periodo 2024 2027 tanto
en forma de préstamos como de
subvenciones
hasta 2027 la brecha fiscal de Ucrania
es de unos 60.000 millones de euros las
necesidades para una recuperación rápida
además son de unos 50.000 millones de
euros eso hace un total de 110.000
millones de euros hasta 2027 que no
están cubiertos por lo tanto ayer
propuse a los Estados miembros de la
Unión Europea cubrir el 45% de esta
brecha esto nos da un total de 50.000
millones de euros para Ucrania mientras
sucede esta importante cita en Londres
Francia reunirá a la comunidad
internacional para buscar un nuevo pacto
financiero mundial esto es una de las
prioridades de Manuel macron Así es eso
a partir de mañana pero hoy decenas de
activistas se congregaron en
inmediaciones de la Torre Eiffel de
París previo a este encuentro del jueves
y del viernes en el que representantes
de un centenar de países también la
sociedad civil y el sector privado así
como las grandes instituciones
institucionales o internacionales
también van a revisar las reglas del
sistema financiero mundial con el clima
en el centro del debate en el Liceo dice
que el objetivo es que ningún país del
mundo tenga que elegir entre la
reducción de la pobreza y la protección
del planeta se ha conocido que entre las
propuestas de Francia están la
aplicación de una tasa a las emisiones
de carbono del transporte marítimo así
como la reestructuración de la deuda de
los países con menos recursos y también
la inclusión de cláusulas en los
préstamos que firmen estos países que
contemplen la posibilidad de que los
puedan eximir de pagos en caso de que
tengan
catástrofes climáticas
cuando hablamos de financiamiento no
podemos seguir invirtiendo en
combustibles a fósiles Porque esa es la
causa de la crisis climática
la deuda no es el sur global con el
norte global Por qué les deberíamos
dinero a las personas que causaron la
crisis climática las empresas
multinacionales del Norte global las
Industrias de combustibles fósiles y los
más ricos son los que tienen una deuda
con el hemisferio sur por destruir el
planeta con sus circunstancias y su
codiciado y este es un tema que así
diario de La Crónica de economía la
inflación del Reino Unido que esta vez
se mantuvo estable en mayo Claro que sí
le hemos hecho bastante seguimiento en
8,7% cerró el interanual en el quinto
mes del año lo mismo que en abril
acabemos una curva de cómo ha
evolucionado la inflación en los últimos
meses llegando a un pico en octubre se
mantuvo en dos dígitos durante varios
meses y aunque acumula dos meses
seguidos por debajo de esos dos dígidos
dígitos en los que se mantuvo sigue
siendo la más alta entre las economías
desarrolladas esto ejerce aún más
presión sobre el banco de Inglaterra Un
día antes de su reunión mensual en la
que se espera que suba las tasas de
interés por décimo tercera vez
consecutiva para domar ese obstinado
crecimiento de los precios unos tipos de
interés altos que están afectando
seriamente el acceso a la vivienda
sabemos que existe una enorme presión
para las familias con hipotecas y es un
gran problema para las finanzas
familiares Pero lo único que no ayudaría
a esas familias es intervenir con apoyos
a corto plazo porque eso mantendría la
inflación y las tasas hipotecarias más
altas por más tiempo
me reuniré con los prestamistas
hipotecarios esta semana para preguntar
qué más se puede hacer para aliviar esa
presión en tiempos muy difíciles pero no
haremos nada que signifique mantener la
inflación alta y eso lo que significa es
que la gente tiene que aguantar
básicamente Claro que sí aguantarse
además que los préstamos que ya están lo
suficientemente altos vayan a tener que
seguir subiendo para que controlen esta
inflación tan alta pues insostenible
para los hogares Daniela hay otras
noticias y tiene que ver con tesla que
explora realizar inversiones En la India
hay una reunión de alto nivel que se ha
dado en este contexto cuéntenos usted
pues su director ejecutivo El Magnate
quien ha estado bastante activo en
Europa porque estuvo en varios países de
gira hace un par de semanas
más recientemente ahora volvió a Estados
Unidos y se reunió en Nueva York con el
Primer Ministro de India narendra modi
durante su visita de estado a este país
una visita que podría alentar a más
empresas estadounidenses a considerar
invertir en este país del sur de Asia
que recordemos es el más poblado del
mundo a medida que buscan reducir su
dependencia de China para actividades
relacionadas con la fabricación y es que
recordemos que la planta más grande de
tesla está en China y ahora esta firma
de vehículos eléctricos desvía su mirada
soy fanático de modi tengo que decirlo
realmente se preocupa por India porque
nos está presionando para que hagamos
inversiones significativas allí que es
algo que tenemos la intención de hacer
solo estamos tratando de encontrar el
momento adecuado él dice que es un Big
fan de narendra Pues yo también sería
fan si me permitieran invertir en este
que es el país más poblado del mundo y
que les hace competencia a China en este
caso Bueno pues de todas maneras pues
Ángel a Estados Unidos es la tercera
mayor fuente de inversión extranjera
para india con más de 60 mil millones de
dólares invertidos entre 2000 y 2023
esta según datos oficiales en datos de
cierre de este tema bien y vamos a
llegar ahora a nuestra cifra del día que
me parece es que ni siquiera sé cómo
describirla es impactante
porque mire la cifra tiene que ver con
un error contable de 6.200 millones de
dólares y es fue cometido por el
pentágono nada más y nada menos que por
el pentágono una cosa es uno de
equivocarse en sus finanzas personales y
otra cosa es que lo haga el pentágono
hundirlo en una tecla sí Exacto Un día
normal una tecla pero mire el el error
6.200 millones de dólares y es que el
departamento militar de Estados Unidos
reconoció que sobreestimó el valor de
las armas que ha enviado a Ucrania en
los últimos dos años la Casa Blanca
había estimado que hasta el momento se
habían comprometido más de 40 mil
millones de dólares en asistencia de
seguridad para este país desde que fue
invadido por Rusia pero ahora se da
cuenta de que en realidad ha
proporcionado menos de 34 mil millones
de dólares como resultado el
departamento Ahora tiene dinero
adicional en sus arcas para seguir
apoyando a Ucrania en su contra ofensiva
contra los rusos ya quisiera uno
equivocarse así que le sobre plata Bueno
aunque también los contadores dicen que
cuando sobra es que falta es que falta
Sí señora a mí me encanta ese dicho
Daniela Muchísimas gracias a ustedes y
nos vemos para el siguiente bloque acá
nos vemos en una hora
[Música]